so one of the the the YouTube viewers
asked me to do this problem and it
looked like a pretty good problem so I
thought I would record a quick video on
it so the problem is this F of G of X
now if I get this right is equal to two
times the square root of x squared plus
one minus one over all of that over the
square root of x squared plus one plus
one and f of X is equal to 2x minus one
over X plus one and the question is if
we know that F of G of X is equal to
this fairly complex looking expression
and that f of X is equal to this then
what is G of X well we can actually do
this problem by kind of just looking at
it because F of G of X what we do is we
took everywhere where we see an X we
replace it with G of X so f of G of X
would look like this and I'll do it in
another color so let's say F of G of X
and let's say we don't know what G of X
is will be like this everywhere we swear
we saw an X we replace it with G of X
right because so it would be 2 times G
of X minus 1 over G of X plus 1
and we also know that F of G of X is
equal to this thing right I mean here we
just took the G of X and put it in of f
of X V and we wrote the G of X in the
expression but we know that that is
equal to this expression up here so that
is also equal to two times the square
root of x squared plus 1 minus 1 all of
that over x squared plus 1 plus 1 and I
think now at this point you can kind of
pattern match and you can see what G of
X is right 2 times something minus 1
right 2 times something minus 1 2 times
something minus 1 in the numerator and
that's something plus 1 in the
denominator
that's something plus 1 in the
denominator so in either case we have G
of X is equal to the square root of x
squared plus 1 and actually in the
example he sent me he gave there was a
bunch of choices and if you were given
the choices then all you have to really
do is take each of the choices for G of
X and replace them in for X in this
expression and then see which of those
choices for G of X ends up with this
expression actually we could do it I
mean he gave the choice well let me see
let me delete let me delete some of this
whoops wrong color I wanted to do it I
want to do it let me see if I can do any
better
oh there you go better that's correct
all right so just as I wanted you to see
that you could do the problem even with
if you weren't given any choices but if
you are given choices the the problem
actually even becomes a little bit more
straightforward so the choices were you
know f will actually erase some of it it
was given that f of X is 2 X minus 1
over X plus 1 and then they said which
of the following is G of X so you know G
of X is equal to and they give these
choices a square root of x be square
root of x squared plus 1 which we just
figured out was actually the answer see
X D x squared and then e x squared plus
1 and the way you do this problem if if
you just by looking at it you didn't you
know the method we just saw saw that you
know if you just replaced X with square
root of x squared plus 1 everywhere then
you'd get F of G of X the other option
is you just take each of these and say
well what is f of if you replaced X with
this term everywhere what do you get
well then you'd get 2 times the square
root of x minus 1 over the square root
of x plus 1 and that's not what we have
up here then if you took this and you
replaced it for X everywhere so if you
took this expression you replace it for
X everywhere then you would get this
expression so you would know that this
would been the answer if you just
replaced X with X you would just get
when you you just get this over again
which does not equal this so that
doesn't work if if G of X was this then
F of G of X would be let's see
everywhere we see an X you would put an
x squared so it would be 2x squared
minus 1 over x squared plus 1 which does
not equal this and
similarly if G of X was this term right
here then F of G of X would be would be
2 times x squared plus 1 minus 1 over x
squared plus 1 plus 1 which you know you
could simplify this a bit but that still
doesn't equal this and so this once
again if you're given the choices you
just try this out and if you replace
this expression everywhere where you see
an X right everywhere where you see an X
and you replace in this expression you
get these and that's what the question
essentially was asking us so hopefully I
didn't confuse everyone too much and
hopefully this was a helpful for the
viewer who asked me to do this I'll see
y'all later bye